ROB DODSON: Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Today on the podcast, we're
going to be taking a look back
at our old core pages example.
We're going to revise it so
it uses the new iron pages
element.
Let's check it out.
OK, so this is what we're
going to be building today.
It is a cat-alogue.
Get it?
Yeah.
And it's basically kind of
like a little image carousel.
So you can see it's got these
Next and Previous buttons.
As I click on them, it cycles
through different photos
of cats.
And you can see here that there
is this text field right here
and, as I change that
index, it is also
updating which cat photo we
are currently looking at.
And so to build
this whole thing,
we're going to use the
new iron pages element.
Now, looking at our source
for our index file here,
you can see that I've
already got my web components
polyfills in place.
I've already gone ahead and
imported my cat-alogue element,
and I've actually dropped it
into the page here as well.
So we're pretty much
already set up to go.
Now, thing that I
want to point out
is that I've got this
images directory over her,
and, inside of there, I've just
got a few photos of some cats.
These are taken from a member
of the Polymer Eng team's
own feline friend
here that we're
using for our example,
which is pretty cool.
Now, in the cat-alogue
element definition,
you can see that this looks
like a pretty typical Polymer
element.
At the top, we are
importing Polymer HTML
to make sure that dependency
is loaded and ready for us.
That one has an
ID of cat-alogue,
which matches the is property
that we have down here
in the Polymer constructor.
And the first thing
that I'm going to do
is just add a style to our
element to style the host.
So we're styling the
tag itself, and I'm
sending it to display block.
And I typically do this
for many of my elements,
just because, by default, custom
elements are displayed inline,
and usually I want things to be
either block or inline block.
So I always do this first
to avoid any style weirdness
down the line.
Now, with that in place, I'm
ready to go ahead and just
import iron pages.
I've already installed
it using Bower.
So I'm just going to pull it
out of the Bower components
directory and drop it
into my element here.
Then I can use this handy
iron pages snippet to spit out
some iron pages boilerplate.
This snippet, by the way, is
part of my snippets package.
So I've got snippets for both
Sublime, which you can get over
here, and snippets for Atom,
which you get over here.
They are really, really
useful, and they are set up
to support the iron elements
and the paper elements,
so it makes it a little bit
easier to write code like this.
And you'll see here
that iron pages
looks a lot like the
old core pages element.
It has a selected
attribute, and this
defines which of
these sections will
be displaying at any one point.
Right now, it's just
defaulting to 0,
so it'll be this
first section here,
and I'm going to add a little
bit of content to this thing.
I'm just going to drop
in some image tags,
and these are going to
link up to our cat photos.
And I've given them all Alt
attributes for accessibility,
and I also want to give them
all an explicit height of 375
pixels.
So I'm going to give
them a pic class,
just so I can style them.
And then I'm just going
to give them a height,
just for the sake
of this demo, so
that we don't have
images that are
all wonky and different sizes.
So now we can actually
preview this thing.
And because iron pages is set
to display its first section
element, we get our
very first cat photo
showing up on screen,
which is pretty rad.
Now, the next thing
I want to do is
create those buttons that
let me toggle back and forth
between different cat photos.
So to do that, I'm going to
create a div underneath my iron
pages, and I'm just going
to call it controls.
And, inside of here,
I'll just draw then
a couple of vanilla, just
regular, old HTML buttons.
But the one thing
that's different
is that I'm going to give them
some of these declarative event
bindings or event
handlers, I should say.
So these are really useful.
These are features that
Polymer adds for you
to set up event listeners.
The nice thing about these is
that not only do they set up
the event listener, but they
handle removing the event
listener when the
element is taken out
of the Dom, which is really
handy for preventing things
like memory leaks.
So right now I
don't know what I'm
going to do with
these methods, but I'm
going to go ahead and
just sort of stub them out
in my prototype.
So I'll go ahead
and I'll stub out
Go Previous as well as Go Next.
And the reason why I don't know
what I'm going to do with these
is because I haven't really dug
into the Docs for iron pages
yet.
So I don't really know how to
tell it to go next or back.
To do that, we will hop
over to the elements catalog
at elements.polymer-project.org
and scope out the iron elements
and kind of scroll down the
page until we find iron pages,
which is right down
here at the bottom.
And I'll boost this
up a little bit,
just so you can kind of
see this page a bit better
because there's a couple
things that I really
want to point out.
The first is this source button.
So this is something
that we just recently
added to the catalog.
And what this does is,
as the name implies,
it allows you to go
to the actual GitHub
repo for the element that
you are interested in.
So you can go here and, if
you want to file an issue,
this is the place to do it.
So you go to the element
source, you go to its repo,
and you file an issue
specifically to that tag.
And then the other
thing you can do here,
obviously, is go and read
the source for the element.
And this is super
handy when you're
trying to learn like what's
going on inside of an element.
The other thing that
I want to point out
that maybe some folks miss is
this little behaviors panel
down here.
So right now you're
looking at iron pages,
and you can see that it's got
this one property that it says
that it defines,
but actually, we
know that there are these two
behaviors down here that it's
implementing, which means,
if you recall from one
of our previous episodes
where we discussed behaviors,
we know that it's actually
mixing in additional properties
and methods that we
should have access to.
So if we go down and click on
the iron Selectable Behavior,
we can see that there are
several properties that
are element implements,
and in fact, we've
got some methods
down here as well.
So we've got methods for
selecting a specific value,
selecting Next and selecting
Previous, et cetera.
So that's actually
what I'm going
to use in those stubbed
out methods that I created.
I'm going to use these Select
Next and Previous methods.
So back in my
elements definition,
I'm going to give
iron pages an ID,
and this is just so I can
select it more easily using
Polymer's Automatic Node finding
so I don't have to do query
select or anything like that.
And I just called it Pages.
And now inside of go
prev, I can say this,
.$ pages to target that element,
and call Select Previous
and then go next.
I will do the same thing
but, this time, I'll
call Select Next.
So now I can switch
back to Chrome,
and I've got my Next
and Previous buttons
and our sort of cat-alogue
image carousel type thing
is now a bit more interactive
and we can flip through
all these beautiful cat photos.
Now, the next thing I want to
do is add that little text input
in the middle, so
I can see which cat
photo I'm currently viewing.
To do that, I will go back
to my element definition,
and I'm just going to drop
in a regular, old input type
equals text element.
And the interesting
thing here is
to note that I'm going to
create a binding in its value,
and I'm going to call my
scope variable selected,
so that will be the shared
name for this bound value.
But notice here
that I'm also going
to add two colons after this
and type the word input.
So what is going on here?
Well, Polymer's
data binding system
is all secretly based on events.
So when you have a
property in your element,
maybe something called age,
for instance-- so let's see.
So we have a property
called age, right?
When this property changes, if
you've set it to notify true,
it is actually going to fire
an event called age changed.
And Polymer listens
for these events
to know when it should
update its data bindings.
But in the case of
native elements,
they fire their own
events when they change.
The text input element fires
this input event anytime
it changes, and so we need to
teach Polymer about this event.
We need to teach it
that hey, we want
this binding to
update whenever you
hear this event being fired.
So that's what we're doing
with this special syntax here,
and this is how you can bind
to native HTML elements.
OK, so with that set up, I can
go back up to my iron pages
element, and I can replace
its hard-coded selected
value with that
same scope variable,
and then I can just define
a property on my element,
for selected.
I'll type it to number, and I'll
give it a default value of 0.
So now, if we go ahead
and preview this thing,
we've got that 0
value down there,
and you can see it's changing
as we click Next and Previous.
We can also type
in the text input,
and because it's firing
that input event,
we know to update
our bindings when
that changes there as well.
Now, one of things
I want to do is
make those controls lay out a
bit nicer and, in Polymer 0.5,
we always talked about
layout attributes.
I used them in every
demo I ever did.
In Polymer 1.0,
those have now been
moved to their own repo that
is called Iron Flex Layout.
I'm going to import
Iron Flex Layout,
and you can see here
it's got a special path
that I'm using here.
So it's iron flex
layout/classes/iron flex
layout.html.
And that's actually going to
load a bunch of CSS classes
that I can use for Flexbox.
So we've switched from
attributes to classes now,
but it's basically the exact
same thing from Polymer 0.5
land.
It's all the Flexbox shortcuts
that you know and love.
So on my controls
div, I will add
layout, horizontal
and justified, and now
these guys layout really
nice, and we can still
toggle through them.
So this is just super useful.
I know a lot of
folks were wondering
where layout attributes went,
so that is where they are.
They're off in Iron
Flex Layout now.
And, for every element, if
you want to use those classes,
you'll need to import
them so that they
work within that scope.
So important thing
to note there.
Now, the last thing
I want to show off
is a feature that was very
popular in Polymer 0.5, which
was sometimes people
didn't want to have
a numeric selected index.
So they would use
this special property
or the special attribute called
value adder, value attribute.
They would add that to
their core pages element,
and they would then
specify an attribute
on all of their sections that
you should look for when you're
trying to update this thing.
This has been replaced in
Polymer 1.0 with iron pages.
Is now called
adder for selected.
So we're going to use this
instead of the old value adder
to say that we're going to
create an attribute called data
cat, and this is just
a made-up attribute.
I'm going to add it
to all of my sections,
and I'm going to give it a
value that sort of typifies
what is in that section.
So this, since
it's a pretty cat,
its data cat value is pretty.
This is a vacation
cat, so it's vacation.
Hacker cat gets hacker.
Now, what's going to happen
is when that selected value
changes to some
string, iron pages
is going to look through
these different sections.
And let's say the
string is hacker.
It's going to look through
the different sections
and be like who has a
matching hacker data cat?
Ah, this guy, right here.
And it's going to make
this the selected item.
So if I go down and I just
change my selected property
to a string and
default it to hacker,
now when we go in
preview, you'll
see that the text
input has hacker,
and as we're flipping through
the different sections,
it changes to our
different data cat values.
And we can type
in a new one here.
It's going to
disappear for a second
because it sort of goes null for
a bit, but we can type in ones
and see those
different cats as well.
So there you have it.
Nice and simple, and with
some pretty small updates,
we're up and running again.
That's it for this week, folks.
Be sure to click that
little subscribe button.
If you have questions
for me, leave them
down in the comments below.
As always, thank you
so much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]